on Wednesday January 8th a Ukraine
International Airlines jetliner crashed
shortly after takeoff from Tehran
killing all 176 passengers and crew
members on board the crash occurred
hours after Iran fired a missile strike
at US forces in Iraq in retaliation for
the killing of a top Iranian general
according to US officials and others the
early evidence suggests the flight a
boeing 737-800 was shot down by Iranian
missiles we have intelligence from
multiple sources including our allies
and our own intelligence the evidence
indicates that the plane was shot down
by an Iranian surface-to-air missile
this may well have been unintentional
this new information reinforces the need
for a thorough investigation into this
matter the process for determining the
cause of a plane crash can take months
or even years and often involves
coordination between different countries
but this time with heightened tensions
between the u.s. and Iran the process is
facing complications Iranian officials
had earlier said the plane suffered a
technical fault a spokeswoman for the
ukrainian President Vladimir zolensky
said Ukraine is interested in finding
the truth therefore I asked all our
international partners if you have any
evidence to assist the investigation
please provide it international protocol
lays down specific guidelines for
conducting post crash investigations
it's a very fluid process is concurrent
our actions a lot of things are taking
place at the same time dr. Daniel quasi
adhigam is a former investigator with
more than two decades of experience in
aviation investigations are usually
conducted under the auspices of the
government of the country the crash
takes place in a country of recurrence
is taking a lead on the accident
the country of registry and operated
aircraft will be notified so that they
can send in work or an accredited
representative to be part of the
investigation the country of design and
manufacture of aircraft is going to be
part of it caso
Majesty coldest in a more typical
accident probe involving a US
manufactured plane at least some us
safety experts would be on their way to
the site within a day or two but given
the diplomatic and security issues
clouding this accident decisions about
u.s. participation are in limbo
dr. Rock'em said that countries with a
high portion of citizens aboard the
flight may also become involved in the
investigation even under less fraught
circumstances collaboration between
multiple countries can be difficult dr.
adam said that in previous crashes like
ethiopia Airlines flight 302 healthy
diplomatic relations made it safe for
the two countries to collaborate but
even then investigators tousled over
where to send the planes black boxes by
any skis because of the peculiar
situation where the two of them cannot
reconcile a third party entity might
suffice so what could happen is that in
such a situation
Ike you might broker a dead body most
likely the French or the Germans might
be brought in by the Iranians want to do
the readouts once an investigation
shifts international security or
military issues civil investigators
generally are relegated to a marginal
role if they have hard evidence is based
on maybe satellite photography which is
sort of irrefutable then the dynamics
change it becomes a criminal
investigation well that happens
international treaties about data
sharing and broad participation no
longer apply and participants tend to be
focused on protecting intelligence
sources despite the hurdles the Iranian
authorities have indicated through
intermediaries including the Civil
Aviation arm of the United Nations they
want the US National Transportation
Safety Board to provide technical
assistance in the normal course this
also would means some level of
participation from the Federal Aviation
Administration Boeing and General
Electric Company which made the planes
jets with a French joint venture partner